JOANNA SMITH: Hey, everybody,
and welcome to "Google+
Developers Live--
Come Auth with Us." I'm Joanna
Smith, and I'm a developer
programs engineer for Google+.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And I'm Silvano
Luciani, and I'm as
well a developer programs
engineer on Google+.
And this week, we are
exceptionally coming to you
from our studio in New York
City, where we are for our
Google+ Sign-In boot camps.
JOANNA SMITH: We're very excited
to be on our global
tour for these Sign-In boot
camps, but even more exciting
is that today we actually get to
have our special guest with
us live, breathing here in the
room, and not by Hangout.
So everyone please welcome our
Google+ developer expert Allen
Firstenberg.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Hi, Joanna.
It's great to be here.
Thank you very much.
It's great to see you guys
in the New York office.
Glad to see you over on this
side of the country.
And I'm Allen Firstenberg,
I'm a Google
developer expert with Google+.
And I'm glad to be helping
out on today's show.
JOANNA SMITH: Fantastic.
So last week we showed you how
easy it is to add Google+
Sign-In to your website
using JavaScript.
And basically what you can do is
by adding Google+ Sign-In,
you bring the power of
Google to your site.
And when a user is signed in,
you get this OAuth token so
that you can make calls on their
behalf to the API while
they're active in your site.
But that's when you're
using client-side.
But there's more to it, and to
better understand your user
and what's right for you, we're
going to go over the
different possible flows
for authentication.
So there's three
of them, right?
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yes, Joanna.
Spot on.
We have three different options,
and today we are
going to do a work through
of all the
three different options.
And we will use different
tools.
We will use a sample-- it's
a very small sample--
we will use the Google OAuth
2.0 Playground, and we will
show you some of the source
code from one of our
quick-starts--
the PHP quick-starts.
JOANNA SMITH: So what
do you think, Allen?
How's that sound?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I think
it sounds good.
I think one of the important
things that people should take
away from this is that what
we're covering today isn't
just applicable to Google+
Sign-In, it's applicable to
everything across the board
of all of Google's APIs.
So if you understand the OAuth
flow from this, you'll be able
to apply it in a wide variety
of other tools that are
available from Google.
JOANNA SMITH: That's a
really good point.
Thank you.
Sometimes it's hard for us to
remember that for developers
there's more than
just our API.
So it's good to have
reminders of that.
So let's get started with
the client-side flow.
And this is what we showed you
guys last week in particular.
And when you're using our
Google+ Sign-In button, you
basically get this
flow for free.
And it's really simple
and straightforward.
But the key to remember is
that when you're using
client-side authentication,
you're able to get an access
token that allows you to make
calls on behalf of the user
while they are active
in your app.
And that's the key piece-- as
long as they're in your app,
you're good to go.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So we
can show an example.
It's our big red
Sign-In button.
We showed you last week how to
place it in your web page and
how to integrate it
in your website.
What we want to show you
this week is what
is the OAuth result.
What is the object that
it's returned after--
when the Sign-In call
back is called after
a successful login.
So when I click Sign-In, in this
case we are seeing our
familiar content dialogue.
It's full screen.
It went already to that
page because I'm full
screen on my monitor.
When I click Accept,
I'm back to my app.
And what I'm doing in this
sample is just dumping the
content of the object that is
returned to our call back.
That's a lot of stuff, as
you can see in there.
But I want to focus on
just two values.
The first one I want to focus
on is the access token.
So this one.
And as you can see, this is what
the client library will
use to sign the request that
you do to our API.
This token will be valid
for one hour.
When you use this flow, what
happens is that we have a
Sign-in mode that is called
Immediate Mode, which means
that if you already
gave content--
if the user has already given
content to your app--
when the user will be back.
If their access token has
expired, we will go to an
automatic flow.
We will give you another access
token, and then you
will be able to start again
making requests to the Google+
API, or any other API,
as Allen pointed.
The second thing I want to
show you is the code.
So this code, remember about
this because we will see this
in a while in the other
two flows that we
will present to you.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: So I think
one of the important things to
understand about when you're
going to be using this sort of
thing is primarily when you're
working with the JavaScript
libraries, and you're
restricting all of your access
from the client where you want
to be displaying things from
JavaScript, controlling things
from JavaScript, and you're
essentially going to be letting
the user connect
directly from the page that's
presented back to Google's
servers and contacting the
Google servers for that data.
So I think this is where you're
going to be seeing the
most use for this
particular flow.
SILVANO LUCIANI: True.
JOANNA SMITH: So Allen, you use
client-side a lot, right?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: It's
primarily most of what I do
these days is I tend to create
a lot of JavaScript mock-ups
and keep all of the work inside
JavaScript itself,
bothering my server as
little as possible.
JOANNA SMITH: And do you do that
because it's simpler or
faster, or is it just
your favorite?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: It depends.
It really depends on the project
that I'm working on at
any given time.
So most of the work that I'm
doing these days pretty much
is staying within
the client-side.
There is no need to
talk to my server.
My server doesn't need to get a
lot of information, doesn't
need to control a lot of
what the user is doing.
I just want the user to be
communicating with Google as
much as possible, as directly
as possible.
JOANNA SMITH: That
makes sense.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: And
communicating with me far less.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
That makes a lot of sense.
And so that was client-side,
which you've now
seen several times.
But the second flow we wanted
to talk to you about is the
server-side flow for web
server applications.
And these may access a Google
API while the user is present
in the application or after
the user has left.
And that's what's really
beneficial about the
server-side flow is that you
get this additional refresh
token, and so you have the
ability to [? meet ?]
somewhere else.
But it requires that the server
is able to keep a
secret, and that's what's
really key here.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah, keeping
the client's secret secret.
A non-secret client's secret
doesn't sound very good.
To show you some of the details,
we are going to use
this wonderful tool, which is
the OAuth 2.0 Playground,
which will allow you to inspect
all the different
steps of the different
OAuth flows.
And by using this gear, you
can configure the type of
OAuth flow that you
want to inspect.
JOANNA SMITH: [INAUDIBLE].
SILVANO LUCIANI: In this
case, it will be the
server-side for us.
And the thing that we want to
show to you is how you will
get the refresh token.
And the refresh token is
a long-lived token.
It will actually never expire
until the user revokes the
token or disconnects your app.
And what you can do with the
refresh token is request a new
access token when the access
token that you're using has
expired, which means
after one hour.
So in the first step, we
are asked to select and
authorize an API.
And given that our + API is way
down the list, I already
added the scope.
But this shows you that you
can actually try this with
your own custom scopes.
So when I click Authorize API,
I'm redirected to the full
screen authorization server.
In this case, it's important
to understand that for the
server-side flow this
will always happen.
And that's the reason why when
you configure this type of
flow, you will also need
the redirect URI.
Because after this redirect to
the Google authorization
server, the Google authorization
server will
redirect back the user to your
app, to the redirect URI that
you have specified in the
configuration of the project
on the API consult.
And after I click Accept, in
this case, we go back to the
OAuth Playground with this
because that's what is
configured as redirect
URI for this project.
Now if you can see, in the URL
it's not very big, but the
last part is a code which is
similar to the code that I was
showing to you before returned
by the Sign-In button.
We can use this code to make
an exchange with the Google
authorization server and get
back a new pair of an access
token and the refresh token.
The code is here as well,
and it's more visible.
And I can do the exchange
by clicking
this big blue button--
Exchange Authorization Code.
When I do it, if you want you
can analyze on the right side
what the request was and
what the response is.
But the most important thing
is that I got this pair--
access token and
refresh token.
Now, it's important to
understand that you will get
the refresh token only once and
only after the user has
given consent to your
application.
So given that you are doing
these because you want offline
access to the user data, you
need to store it along with
the user data in your database
or wherever you store data for
your application and
don't lose it.
If you lose it for any reason,
you can force the user to
reauthenticate using the
approval prompt parameter and
setting it to false, but this
will cause the consent
dialogue to be displayed
again to the user,
which could be confusing.
Now, I can use the List Possible
Operations to get all
the operations that the Google+
API, which is the one
that we authorized in this
demo, available.
The other thing that I can do
is go back to step two.
Let me close this.
Go back to the second step.
And there's another gray button,
which is Refresh
Access Token.
And if I click it, you can see
what happens when you want to
actually use a refresh token to
get a new access token that
will last another hour.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: And I think
one of the things that's
important to understand about
this is when you would use
this over the client-side one.
And primarily I use this the
most under one of two
circumstances.
The first is when what I'm doing
on the client-side isn't
very much related to what's
going on with Google itself.
So if my client is almost
exclusively talking to my
server, or if I'm getting some
static information back from
the server, this is when
I would be doing it.
My server's doing all of
the heavy lifting.
The other case when it's doing
it is when I don't have a
client at all.
When basically I need my server
to be able to do things
on my behalf.
So looking outside Google+,
for example, I might be
wanting to write something into
a spreadsheet that's in
Google Drive.
Or I might want to be creating
Google Drive documents for me
to look at later.
Or using the new API, I might
be wanting to create new
moments and have those moments
show up as part
of my Google+ history.
These are cases where there's no
direct client interaction,
so the server needs that refresh
token and needs to be
able to use that refresh
token at any time.
JOANNA SMITH: That's true.
And the other thing is, this
OAuth Playground has been
available on our documentation,
and it's a
really great resource for
you to follow the flow.
So if you're ever a little
confused about OAuth and its
complexities, definitely take
a moment to really step
through and see everything that
happens at each stage,
because this is honestly how I
learned OAuth when I first
started at Google, and I
think it'll be really
good for you too.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Same for me.
JOANNA SMITH: [LAUGHS]
And so the third flow we wanted
to talk to you about is
what we call the one
time code flow.
And it uses this same
authorization code to exchange
to the server to get that access
and refresh token back.
But what's really key here is
that you can actually receive
the code on the client like we
saw earlier, and you can pass
that code securely to your
server in order to do the
exchange for the token so that
you don't have to pass a user
authentication token
around, which could
be unsafe or insecure.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So yeah,
we have a diagram on our
developer's documentation on
developers.google.com.
And this is a scheme of what
Joanna just told you.
So what happens when you use
the Google+ Sign-In, as I
showed you before, you get
an access token, but
you also get a code.
And you can use that code
to perform the exchange.
I will show you now how to
do it using one of our
quick-starts that you can
find in our Google+
repository on GitHub.
As you might already know,
there's quick-starts for many
different languages.
So there's two key
things here.
What I'm showing to you now is
from the index.html of our
quick-start, which is where
we rendered the button.
And then we have some JavaScript
asynchronous call
to a simple backend API
implemented in PHP.
So what happens in this connect
server function is
that we are posting to our
server the code that we
obtained from the Sign-In button
that was in the object
that is returned
to the callback
of the Sign-In button.
One important thing that we
are doing is to avoid
cross-site request forgery,
when we rendered this page
from the server-side, we created
this state which is a
random value.
We rendered the random value
in the parameters of this
invocation, and we save it in
the session so that when we
receive this request on the
server, we can compare the
value with what we stored
in the session.
And you should do it, probably,
in the database.
If they are the same value, then
we can see that this is
our request.
Otherwise, something fishy
might have happened.
If we go to see what happens on
the server-side in our PHP
API, we can use the Google
API client for PHP.
We just have to initialize it
with some standard parameter.
At this point, this function--
the connect function--
is where we post the code.
And what happens here is that
when we receive the code, we
make the exchange with the
Google token endpoint, and
then we make some verification
on the token.
We check that the audience of
the token is our app so that
this token is actually intended
to be for our
application.
And we check that the user that
is tied to the access
token is actually the user
that is trying to
login to our app.
And then we are good to go.
Otherwise, if we found some
problems, some errors, we
return some meaningful error
about what happened and what
went wrong in this exchange.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: And I think
it's important to point out
that these checks are really
very, very important.
One other way that a lot of
people have talked about doing
this sort of thing is handing
the access code from the
client to the server.
And that's just a bad,
bad way to do it.
Using this separate code and
then doing these additional
checks on the server
side is much more
secure, much more reliable.
And it really kind of drives
home the point that Google is
trying to create code and create
flows that are meant to
protect developers and
users combined.
I think one of the great things
about this particular
flow and the way this one works
is that in the end, both
the client and the server
have access to a user's
information, can communicate
with Google
on the user's behalf.
So you can have some of the
JavaScript stuff using the
JavaScript APIs to talk directly
to Google, and the
server ends up with the code,
ends up with the ability to do
the refresh token, ends up with
the ability to do things
on the user's behalf if that's
what you're trying to do.
So that's an important
dual feature.
It's really pretty powerful that
you're allowing this sort
of thing and allowing
it securely.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
And one important thing that
I forgot to mention on the
security point of view
is that this token
is a one time token.
So you can use it only
for one exchange.
And it will expire
pretty soon.
So do the exchange fast.
Because otherwise, you won't
be able to use it.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Where pretty
soon is on the order of
less than a minute or two?
Less than that, if I
remember correctly.
SILVANO LUCIANI: I didn't
give a-- yeah, yeah.
Less than a minute.
I don't remember the exact.
But yeah, I usually
do it immediately.
So yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: And so those
are our three flows.
And it really helps to be able
to decide for yourself as a
developer if you want to focus
primarily on client-side,
primarily on server-side, or if
you feel like you really do
want to make calls on both sides
of your application on
behalf of the user.
And hopefully with a little bit
of this discussion, you'll
be able to figure out which
one's right for you.
But of course if you want to
learn more, definitely check
out our documentation at
developers.google.com/plus,
because that's where we put
everything, including that
really helpful diagram
to track the flow.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yes.
And as I showed you, our
project's on GitHub.
You can find the quick-starts
with our showings
on different approach--
pure client-side with the
JavaScript, mix the one time
code exchange with the Python,
Java, PHP, Ruby, and C#.
And then there's also PhotoHunt,
which is an
end-to-end sample application.
So it's giving you an example
of a more complex
authentication scenario that
involves also like mobile
clients for Android and iOS.
JOANNA SMITH: And of course, if
you have any questions, let
us know in our Google+
Developers community.
I check that every single day to
see what's going on and if
anyone's looking
for some help.
And of course, we have Stack
Overflow with our Google+ tag,
which we also check daily.
And then the final resource
is our Issue Tracker.
And if you find a bug, or if you
have a feature request, go
ahead and check there
or file a new one.
But if you find one that you
like, star it, because I use
those stars every week when I
triage those issues, and the
stars are what tell us what's
important and which things we
need to move into our internal
bug system and which feature
requests need to be
sent along to PMs.
So definitely take the time to
star an issue that you find
important, because that's
going to be really key.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Yeah.
I know I always hang
out on Stack
Exchange and Stack Overflow.
So issues that show up there--
I enjoy reading them.
I enjoy getting the perspectives
of other
developers on what you're
trying to do.
And for that I always turn
to our Google+ Developers
community on Google+ itself.
We've had a lot of good
exchanges there.
Always good to hear how other
people are using this and also
the problems that you're having,
because that helps me
and it helps the team improve
the documentation and improve
the resources for all of us.
JOANNA SMITH: Definitely.
If you aren't getting what
you need to out of our
documentation, you need to be
letting us know because our
whole job is to help developers
succeed, and that's
what we really care about.
So definitely speak up about
good and bad things.
It really helps us out.
And that's our show for today.
But before we go, I just want
to take a moment to thank
Allen for coming up and
being here with us.
It's great to be able
to talk to our GDEs.
And of course our other two GDEs
are Abraham Williams and
Gerwin Sturm.
And they're incredibly useful
resources, so if you see them
hanging out on the internet
definitely give their words
some weight, because
they matter.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: They do.
JOANNA SMITH: And thanks
for being here.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I'm
glad I could be here.
Thanks for having me and thanks
for all the support you
guys give to all of the
developers out there.